ملايين الامريكيين استيقظوا على مشهد سماء
برتقاليه اللون غيرت معالم المدن من حولهم
اصوات السعال بعضهم عاليه ولا يستطيعون
التنفس جيدا كل ذلك بسبب حرائق الغابات في
كندا التي لا تزال مستعره حتى اللحظه فكيف
بدات هذه الحرائق هذه ليست المره الاولى
التي تشهد فيها كندا حرائق في فصل الصيف
فهي شائعه في الاقاليم الغربيه حيث ان
موقعها الجغرافي على الخريطه يساهم برفع
درجه حرارتها بشكل اسرع من بقيه مناطق
الكوكب ومع ازمه التغير المناخي شهدت كندا
هذا العام ربيعا اكثر دفئا ومستوى اعلى من
الجفاف اضافه لموجه حر قياسيه دفعت
الخبراء للاعتقاد انه سبب الكارثه كندا
شهدت اكثر من 414 حريقا
239 منها خرجت عن السيطره حتى اللحظه
الخبراء حذروا من ان البلاد ستشهد اسوا
كارثه على الاطلاق
خاصه انهم يتوقعون استمرار الظروف
المناخيه الحاره والجافه حتى اخر فصل
الصيف لكن السلطات في المقابل تامل ان
يؤدي هطول الامطار المتوقع في نهايه
الاسبوع لتبريد الطقس والتخفيف من حده
الازمه